hi at the W Hotel right now and I just  was probably the most scared out of a  beam and the person who scared me was  let me show you I'm sure the person who  just scared the living daylights only  they're very scary so here's what we got  massive hotel we just walked in we don't  know the room layout at all I think we  were walking actually around this way I  don't know if you there to pick this up  so well on the camera I see my  reflection like this and so so literally  I just do this walk in and I'll turn and  three times on the bed shaking well  Russell is laughing at me  we should keep recorded that so that's  my embarrassing story of the day you  know what the guy was so much bigger  than me he was so much stronger than  mean he was so much taller than me  and he wasn't me so there's some life  lessons in there somewhere but a great  venue see view rooms as you can see you  can just see us on the camera